bonjour Zimbabwe Fellows amublance
suite à l'allocution que nous avons prononcée le 30
novembre 2017 dans laquelle nous pensons que notre émission principale en
tant que Mobile Broadcasting
Corporation et The Herald ont été ordonnées de
ne pas rendre publique la situation dans notre
pays est passée à un autre niveau
tout d'abord, nous souhaitons assurer la nation
que  Son Excellence le président de la
République du Zimbabwe et
commandant en chef de ces
Forces de défense mobiles, le camarade ROG Maccabi et
sa famille sont sains et saufs et leur
sécurité est garantie, nous ne
ciblons que les criminels autour de lui qui
commettent des crimes qui causent des
problèmes sociaux  et la souffrance économique dans le
pays afin de les traduire en
justice dès que nous aurons accompli
notre mission, nous espérons que la situation
reviendra à la normale pour les
fonctionnaires, car vous savez qu'il existe un
plan des mêmes individus pour
influencer l'actuel  engagement qui
se déroule dans la sphère politique à
la fonction publique, nous sommes contre cet
acte d'en  justice et nous avons l'intention de
protéger chacun d'entre vous contre cela au
pouvoir judiciaire les mesures et la manière dont j'entendais
faire en sorte qu'en tant
que bras indépendant de l'État, vous
puissiez exercer votre
autorité indépendante sans crainte d'être
entravé comme cela a été le cas  avec
ce groupe d'individus
à nos parlementaires, votre
rôle législatif est d'une
importance capitale pour la paix et la stabilité dans
ce pays et nous souhaitons qu'une
dispense soit créée qui vous permette
de servir vos circonscriptions politiques respectives
selon les
principes démocratiques à la généralité  du peuple
du Zimbabwe, nous vous exhortons à rester calme
et à limiter les déplacements inutiles, mais
nous encourageons ceux qui sont employés et
ceux qui ont le sens des affaires dans la
ville à poursuivre leurs activités normales
comme d'habitude, notre souhait est que vous jouissiez de vos
droits et libertés et  que nous remettions
notre pays dans une dispense qui
permette le développement des investissements et la
prospérité que nous tous
pour lesquels beaucoup de nos concitoyens ont payé le
sacrifice suprême les partis politiques
nous vous exhortons à décourager vos membres
de se livrer à des comportements violents
envers les jeunes nous vous appelons à prendre conscience
que l'avenir de ce pays vous appartient
ne vous laissez pas séduire par  les sales pièces
d'argent soient disciplinées et restent
attachées à l'éthos et aux valeurs de
cette grande nation à toutes les églises et
les organisations religieuses du Zimbabwe,
nous vous appelons, vous et vos congrégations,
à prier pour un pays et à approcher l'
évangile de l'amour, de la paix, de l'unité et du
développement
pour mettre notre peuple et le monde au-delà de
nos frontières, nous souhaitons qu'il soit
très clair qu'il ne s'agit pas d'une
prise de contrôle militaire du gouvernement, ce que
font ces forces de défense mobiles,
c'est pacifier une situation politique,
sociale et économique dégénérative dans notre
pays qui, si elle n'est pas résolue  peut
entraîner une communauté violente, nous
appelons tous les anciens combattants à jouer un
rôle positif pour assurer la
stabilité de la paix et u  nité dans le pays
aux membres de ces forces plus avancées
ou le congé est annulé et vous devez tous
retourner à votre caserne avec
effet immédiat à nos
chefs traditionnels respectés, vous êtes les
gardiens de notre culture, coutumes,
traditions et patrimoine et nous
vous demandons de fournir  leadership et direction
à vos communautés pour le bien de l'
unité et du développement dans notre pays
aux autres services de sécurité, nous vous exhortons
à coopérer pour le bien de notre pays
qu'il soit clair que nous avons l'intention de faire
face aux menaces à la sécurité humaine dans
notre pays donc tout  la provocation
sera accueillie avec une réponse appropriée
et aux médias nous vous invitons à signaler de manière
loyale et responsable nous vous remercions
vous vous